[Music]  [Music]  fourth-of-july  I'm fit the patron celebrate in it with  all the girls that we know yet today is  the day they put paper the quill said  the government can't be all up for your  grill  kielbasa and hot dogs brats a sauerkraut  box it's like we're living in Anthony  Weiner's outbox Millie's pouring drinks  yeah it's gonna be monstrous every  swimming with the shirt on I'm  self-conscious SuperSoaker fights but  nobody is getting me clean from that  water like my name was Ted Kennedy it's  the land of the free we put paper to  quill and said the government can't be  all up in your grill cuz excuse me about  that too rare too big too salty too  risky to French choking hazard we gotta  shut this tab is pretty dangerous back  here I saw fireworks we're gonna  sandwich  [Music]  you  [Music]